let's go enough TV let's figure out why
we're here
well I grew up with Lego and they
exploded in the last 10 years every
dream you could imagine of what you
wanted Legos to be has come true
practically and I think the parents will
love a lot of the the nostalgic kind of
licenses that we've got in there
Ghostbusters and Back to the Future that
everyone grew up with those films ain't
afraid of no ghost we wanted everything
to be as authentic as possible so we've
got Michael J Fox back as Marty McFly
I'm Christopher lawyer to stop her out
does that mean we're going ah to the
Future in and Batman our partners honey
who could have fought did you hit your
head
Gary oh who is our Vil Lord Forte who
gives an amazing performance and you
won't be needing those lovely ruby
slippers anymore my we've got Chris
Pratt reprising his role as Emmett as
well as Owen I wonder if the Raptors
miss me Elizabeth Banks playing wildstar
Jimmy middle Zealand do you mean middle
Zealand do you mean middle Zealand I
kind of want to see unikitty get some
goes
action maybe unikitty isn't Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man have a little thing feel
like they both to be misunderstood we've
a sum of an amazing voice cast for this
game that is so freaky deaky every
dimension is mine you are a fool fool
stupid here what hey I love these new
blue horny things
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander eh
it's almost like like we're in a video
game that is the single most ridiculous
thing I've ever heard
it's not just for kids it's for
everybody it's for animals mammals
cold-blooded animals invertebrates
everybody can have it they all
complained break the rules hashtag